mythos quand je quand je suis avec
quelqu'un tu veux y aller japon vous
avez vous avez vous au tube à doha le
tuer moi pour me gallant très long mais
lorsque vous avez été en boîte de nuit
ce serait laquelle
mais à terme ce sera comme ça aurait
lâché la wii bien que je sois céline
vous avez été ou en boîte de nuit
oui ben adda semaine de rentrée à lyon à
lyon il a tellement c'est le moment de
détente avec mon mari mais en vain ce
beau coup en forme et les malades c'est
pas des bois n'a pas la toile et vous
êtes enfin devenir seul leader
il est comme à son père est là
[Rires]
allez avec ton mari comme anne thomas
bouteille à à alata mais ce ne fut pas
normalement ils vont voir que c'est
pourquoi un lion ya des boîtes à paris
mais non alors ouais donc tu as eu ton
pote s'appelait comment la boîte tout
comme du cours est aussi vite que je
t'emmerde tu serais champion olympique
[Applaudissements]
ce serait si tu pourrais aussi touchants
merde je serai championnat bien sûr les
fans car bien oui alors moi je fais pas
beaucoup de gaffes mais quand j'en fait
elles sont difficilement rattrapable nom
de la boîte savoir s'ils n'ont pas goûté
d mais si vous savez mais parce que j'ai
envie de les zapper la passion d'abord
que jamais c'est les noms des
restaurants et le nom des boîtes de mon
art à part écrire mois qui tête avec
plier la boîte à lyon et à la fin des
années je suis en train de taper sur
google à l'oas pour les plus de 80 kg
passe ont eu droit lundi peut raconter
magath n'ont pas laissé la revois texto
à un emballement jeta sur ses membres à
savoir lyon là bas qu'on va la rue avant
la fin de l'émission